that failed
me yeah
so our second speaker is Cynthia Rush
from Colombia and she's going to give
another awesome talk on information
during statistics
[Music]
uh so today I'm going to talk a little
bit about
um variational inference and robustness
so in particular uh the robustness of um
Alpha posteriors and their variational
approximations to uh model specification
so
um all right so just a quick overview so
today I'm going to study the alpha
posterior so this is just our normal uh
posterior right kind of proportional to
the likelihood times the PO uh the prior
but now the likelihood is um scaled by
an alpha Factor that's going to be some
value and zero one so we're going to
study um these objects that Alpha
posterior that I denote like P sub Alpha
and also variational approximations to
the alpha posterior right so uh the the
closest distribution and some
simplifying set in particular the
gaussian mean field
um in terms of KL Divergence and so um
there's been a lot of work uh a lot of
recent work analyzing statistical
properties of these procedures and um
we're we're just trying to contribute um
to this literature by showing that these
procedures when they're properly um
tuned have some uh robustness some
rigorous uh sort of robustness
properties to to miss specification so
that's kind of like the goal uh for
today so this is Joint work with um some
of my colleagues uh Marco Pepe and uh
emilkar um Marcos and stats at Columbia
with me uh Pepe Anna milpar uh
econometricians
um okay so first I just wanted to say a
few words about variational inference to
make sure we're we're all on the same
page and and sort of um set up some of
my uh notation
okay so the the idea right is that um
you know we're thinking about doing
posterior inference um so what does this
mean right well I've uh you know usually
a common thing to do right is um we put
some sort of probabilistic model
um on our data so we can this is you
know something we think of as a joint
distribution
um over the data which is you know my
observable X and then also some hidden
or latent variables um Theta right and
then the idea is kind of we want to use
the data to learn something about Theta
and then you know uh we interpret Theta
as telling us something about you know
the scientific world or whatever problem
we're studying
of course right um you know what we
would like to do is just uh look at this
posterior distribution right
um and you know use that to say
something about Theta but in general
um when the problems are complex
actually calculating this uh posterior
distribution is um more very difficult
right so in particular uh finding this
marginal usually uh involves like a high
dimensional integral and you can't do it
so um you know what people do right is
they uh in some way try to approximate
this posterior distribution so
um one way you might approximate it is
to try to sample from it using mcmc
another way
um you know which we're going to look at
is is variational inference which you
know and mcmc you might think of uh it
turns posterior inference into sampling
variational inference turns posterior
inference into optimization right okay
so um right this is this is what uh
variational inference
um does so this is an image I stole from
uh Dave bly's uh nerds tutorial uh back
in 2016 right so the basic idea is that
um you know we'd like to access this
posterior we can't because we can't
calculate the marginal what I'm going to
do is just find an approximation to it
um you know that minimizes the KL
Divergence where this approximation
comes from some um simplifying like you
know set some some set of simple
distributions
so the first step is to just posit this
variational family these are our simple
distributions
um these are going to be you know
something uh some class of distributions
over uh these hidden variables so in the
image right I have my my true posterior
is up here my like oval here represents
my simplifying class right what I want
to do is try to you know my simplifying
class is going to be parameter
parameterized by new so my goal is to
find the new that minimizes this this KL
Divergence right we usually do it with
some sort of algorithm that updates our
approximation that's the the kind of
squiggly line right so uh you know what
do we do right the variational
parameters that that uh we we select
this is our approximating distribution
are going to be those that minimizes the
the Callback level or Divergence okay so
what we want to do is think about
um the robustness properties of
variational inference uh so robustness
um what I mean today is um robustness to
model mispecification right so the the
basic idea is that we want to
um say something about how well
variational inference performs even if
uh the assumed model is wrong right so
that joint distribution I put over my
data and my my hidden variables
um often this is wrong right it's
usually a simplifying kind of view of of
the world so
um how do these um how do these
procedures perform in in that case so
again
um you know
we're looking at in particular the the
alpha posterior
um and it's it's variational
approximation so what I'm going to study
today is just a variational
approximation that's in um that takes as
a simplifying set the gaussian mean
field this is you know a commonly used
uh sort of variational family and it's
also in some sense the the simplest it
just means I'm going to think about my
hidden variables as being independent
and I'm going to give each of them their
own gaussian distribution so sort of
what we want to estimate here is for
each uh each of these Theta values I I
want to get a I mean and a variance
right so so that's the the idea so um
okay the these Alpha posteriors have
many names in the literature they've
been called tempered posteriors
fractional posteriors power posteriors
it's also a Gibbs distribution
um you know these are these have been
studied um uh for for a long time
um perhaps uh going back even to you
know then the 90s with the work of buff
and Baron and cover who you know had
these sorts of ideas that we can enhance
Beijing procedures by you know somehow
decreasing the influence of the the
likelihood and so
um you know okay so people have been
thinking about these Alpha posterios for
a long time and there was like sort of a
Resurgence of Interest maybe in the like
early 2010s when folks started um
empirically seeing some nice robustness
properties to uh to you know of these of
these Alpha posteriors and so um you
know there's been some recent work uh on
on these things uh but it's often you
know sort of in um you know High
dimensional settings or non-parametric
settings or it's it's mostly empirical
um or heuristic in in some way so kind
of our our first goal when we started
this project um which is what I'm going
to show you today is um you know we
wanted to just see if we could say
something rigorous about the robustness
uh properties and kind of our our like
very standard statistics uh setting
which you know is is parametric and low
dimensional models so low dimensional I
just mean I'm thinking about you know my
data is grow my you know amount of data
is growing but the dimension of that
Theta Vector the hidden variables is is
fixed right
okay
um so no I'm just gonna kind of Define
you know what I mean by by this model
mispecification right so um we're
thinking about uh you know uh modeling
our our data through a parametric family
of of densities right so
um this is just going to be this this
class
um uh cursive cursive p right and so
um if you know the true data generating
process is in the class uh then the
class is correctly specified right so if
I think of P naught as the the the sort
of true data uh generating process if P
naught is in this class we're correctly
specified but if it doesn't belong to
that class we are are mispecified
okay
um and then uh you know the the other
sort of notation I need is
um uh the maximum likelihood estimator
right so this is nothing is like uh
surprising here this is the usual
definition of the maximum likelihood
estimator right I'm thinking about you
know it being defined with respect to my
my model class P that may or may not be
uh correctly specified right
um and we're also going to assume
uniqueness and asymptotic normality of
uh the mle so we're basically just uh
doing this because you know we we're
gonna We would like to say something
rigorous about uh the robustness
properties and you know we want to kind
of emphasize that like I'm this is not
some Edge case where you get robustness
just in like the you when when things
are going as planned you know um you you
kind of get uh uh robustness so the the
ideas here you know we're in this usual
setting where things
um where where things uh you know
perform and kind of in the the way the
way they should so uh when we think
about asymptotic normality of um you
know the maximum likelihood estimator uh
it's going to be centered on some Theta
Star right where this Theta star depends
on like uh whether or not my my model
class P is correctly specified right so
if if it is correctly specified then of
course Theta star is going to be the
Theta that generates the data but if it
if it um isn't then this is just going
to be my pseudo true parameter so it's
the one that's closest uh to the truth
in terms of of kale Divergence right
okay so kind of the first thing uh we we
wanted to to sort of study were just
what are the asymptotic properties of
the alpha posterior and um you know it's
variational approximation so in general
uh you know in in statistics we know
that for like a wide class of models
right the the posterior even under model
mispecification is asymptotically normal
and so the first question was like all
right well if we just throw the alpha in
there does that change anything how does
it change anything and you know even
though we kind of thought that this
might be something that exists in the
literature you know apparently um it
didn't so our first test was to just um
try to look at uh
these sorts of Bernstein Bon mises
results for Alpha posteriors and their
variational approximation so Bernstein
by Muse just means kind of you know
asymptotic uh distribution of of
posteriors
um so in particular
um the first thing we did was kind of
extend to existing results on asymptotic
normality of of posterior distributions
and variational approximations under
mispecification so in particular
um you know for for standard posterior
so like this is like Alpha equals one
posteriors right uh there's a classical
result uh by Klein and vanderbar that
that gives us asymptotic normality under
mispecified models and um uh more
recently by uh yishun Wang and Dave Bly
um there's asymptotic uh normality
results for variational approximations
uh under model specification so our
first goal was to extend these you know
when we do the when we study the alpha
posterior or the variational
approximation to the alpha posterior so
um I'll I'm you know I'm going to say
that but that uh the you know I'll use
the term asymptotically normal but it's
a bit of a you know I'm being a little
loosey-goosey with my language here
right so what I actually mean is that
the total variation between the alpha
posterior or its variational
approximation and a gaussian
distribution which also depends on N
right that total variation goes to zero
so that's that's what I'm saying foreign
okay and so um what we were able to show
is that
um and both these cases so for Alpha
posteriors and for the variational
approximations to the alpha posteriors
we still get the asymptotic normality
so
um first I'll just quickly State some um
assumptions and I'll I'll you know
uh so
the the the first thing we want to study
is the asymptotics of the alpha
posterior itself and so
um it turns out that we we just need the
same assumptions of Klein and vanderbart
um to get the the asymptotic normality
so in particular this requires um uh
some assumption about the the local
asymptotic normality of um the model and
also uh an assumption about the rate of
concentration of um my Alpha posterior
so uh while these are you know so
okay in the statistics Community I you
know I believe that these are probably
about as general of assumptions as we're
going to get for asymptotic uh normality
under mispecification
um
you know if you want to think about you
know extending these results perhaps to
like Beijing neural networks or
something
um we're we're excluding that here right
so in particular like I'm I'm assuming
identifiability and stuff that that
doesn't
um exist for the the Bayesian neural
network so uh while these are you know
if we want asymptotic normality I think
this is as general as we get
um I think you know what we'd like to do
is extend this
um perhaps to more General models but I
think there we won't actually get the
normality
um so uh that you know the future work
is um if we want to to study kind of
robustness of more General Bayesian
models what do we what do we do but
um for now these are these are kind of
classic
um statistical assumptions so in
particular something like this right if
the data is assumed to be IID then it
basically just requires that you have
like a second order Taylor approximation
or at least that's a sufficient um
condition
um so it's it's
um fairly light and so
um okay so the first result is that you
know under those assumptions
um we can show asymptotic normality and
the sense that the total variation
distance between our our Alpha posterior
and a limiting gaussian approaches zero
and so
um the interesting thing here is that
okay so the gaussian so the only thing
that the alpha changes here it doesn't
change the mean so the mean of the
limiting gaussian is still the maximum
likelihood estimator but what it does
change is um it scales this this
variance right so here um the the V
Theta this is like an inverse fissure
information Matrix right
um so it tells us something about the
curvature of our likelihood at um at the
the the pseudotrue parameter
um so what we've done now is Right Alpha
is a value between zero and one so we've
sort of upscaled
um uh the the variance here so
um there's a few ways I guess to to
interpret it one would be like you know
if you throw the alpha on to the
likelihood and the posterior this is
basically saying that um when we think
about asymptotics it's like we're we now
have in Alpha data points instead of in
data points so
um this is sort of slowing down the the
concentration by spreading out the the
the mass
um okay so the the only way it changes
um the the asymptotics is through
upscaling uh the the variance
um okay so we want to play the same game
with the the variational approximation
too so now you know what do we uh what
what are the asymptotics for this
variational approximation to P Alpha and
kind of like you can guess what's going
to happen right so uh the sort of ideas
you know if I know P Alpha limits to
this um gaussian if then I kind of uh
project P Alpha onto the gaussian main
field it's limiting gaussian is going to
be like the original one projected onto
the gaussian mean field right so
um you know okay so basically uh uh what
what this this says right is you know
this is the object we'd like to study
it's the the gaussian mean field
approximation to P Alpha and so um it's
going to limit to basically
um the the sort of density in the
gaussian main field that's closest to
the original limiting um
uh gaussian distribution so basically
all this um this does is you know now
we've kind of diagonalized uh the the
variance here right this is what sort of
the gaussian mean field uh requires us
us to do
um
there's a slightly more
um uh conditions here but I'm not going
to go into too many details um for this
talk though I will mention um in some
sense uh you know kind of a something we
know about like gaussian mean field
variational inference is it
underestimates the variance right so
um the fact that we've kind of upscaled
the variance here is in some sense um I
think the the right idea this is a nice
thing because you know um one of the
issues with with the variational
inference uh here is that you know you
you sort of are under estimating the
variance always which is like kind of
bad you know you you don't want to um
think you don't want to be more sure um
than you are so here are the the alpha
um helps in that way
okay so now using um these asymptotics
uh we'd actually like to to study the
robustness so
um okay the first kind of question was
um how do we measure robustness to to
model mispecification right so
um you know what we'd like to say are
you know or what we'd like to answer
right is you know are the alpha
posteriors or their variational
approximations more robust in some sense
than um just standard Bayesian inference
so kind of alpha equals one uh Bayesian
inference so the first question is how
do we measure robustness and so
um the the idea that we we studied uh
which we believe is due to to Gustafson
um is uh to you know use the KL
Divergence right I'm an information
theorist so like why go too far away
from like the things I know and love
right so um the idea right is we have
two different procedures that lead to
incorrect uh posterior inference right
um you know procedure a procedure B
they're both wrong perhaps due to
monomous specification or limited
computational resources or whatever
we're still going to say one procedure
is more robust than the other if it's
you know uh closer to the truth in terms
of kale Divergence so even though
they're both wrong we can still kind of
preference one if um it gets us closer
to the the truth
so um the object that we'd like to to
study is uh you know this closest
closeness in terms of KL
um of the you know the objects we're
considering to the correct uh posterior
so in particular you know I'm looking at
the KL between the the correct posterior
and um the reported where the reported
here is like either my P alpha or my Q
Alpha that variational approximation
okay so um
all right so to enable like the the
tractability of you know studying um
this object uh we aren't going to assume
that our model classes always
mispecified or always correctly
specified but rather that there's some
um sort of probability Epsilon that
could change with you know uh the the
amount of data
um some probability of mispecification
Epsilon n so uh you know I'll talk I'll
say a little bit more um about this when
I'm interpreting the results but kind of
the short story is if you always assume
that you're mispecified then the results
say then well okay Alpha should be zero
don't use the wrong likelihood in your
analysis if you're always correctly
specified Alpha should be one obviously
you use it because it gives you
information so somehow like the
interesting regime where sort of our
phase transitions occur
um or is this where there's some um some
probability of mispecification so you
know what I sad right is that I wanted
to study uh this right but now if
there's some probability of
mispecification right the meaning of p
correct uh is going to change
according to whether I'm mispecified or
not so what we study are actually like
expected KL divergences right one uh
with the miscon mispecified contribution
and one with the correctly specified
contribution
um so again right what this changes is
the meaning of of P correct right so um
the correct you know okay if we're well
specified right P naught is in my
cursive p uh model class so P correct is
simply P Alpha with Alpha equals one
right it's the true posterior
um if I mispecified
um I'm thinking of P correct as being
some P star which
um I'm gonna think is you know sort of
coming from some parametric model for
the the truth uh kind of the the
important thing here is that uh you know
the thetas in my original model still
have some meaning in this this you know
other other space but now we've been you
know we've also put some Gammas here so
um in in truth right this could actually
be non-parametric like gamma could be
infinite dimensional but we still have
to have some meaning of of theta and the
um
the misspecified case
and so okay so the the object we'd like
to study is then
um um this so if we're thinking about
robustness of of Alpha posteriors
um what we'd like to to study is this
expected KL so um the first term is my
my mispecified contribution right so
it's the kale between you know my my
reported thing over here and the truth
over here but I'm mispecified with
probability Epsilon so the truth is is
this uh P star that comes from my my
other sort of model class and then with
probability one minus Epsilon I'm
correctly specified My Truth Now is
Alpha equals one posterior all right
um so the idea right is that okay so
this is how I'm measuring robustness so
what I'd like to do is find the alpha
that minimizes this expected kale
Divergence right so
um the you know the alpha posteriors for
the alphas giving smaller values of this
KL this is saying that that you know
inference procedure is getting us closer
to the truth so we're more robust to to
miss specification
and um of course I want to play the same
game with variational approximations so
what I've done here is just replace you
know P Alpha is my actual Alpha
posterior Q Alpha is the variational
approximation to it
okay so these are the things I'd like to
study um the problem is it's hard
um you know if we're thinking about in
uh being finite so
um what I what I'm going to to study
instead are kind of the asymptotic
versions of this right so I'm kind of I
have you know my BVM Theory and my back
pocket so now it's where I'm going to
use it so uh instead of studying this
you know finite in sort of thing what
I'm gonna do is replace uh you know
these
um posteriors with their sort of uh
their their limiting gaussians right and
so now I've put myself in a really good
situation because I know uh exactly what
the kale Divergence between uh gaussians
gaussians is right so um you know uh
what what I'm gonna do now right is
study this object and again this is
something that I'd like to minimize uh
with respect to Alpha and then whatever
the minimizing Alpha is this tells me
like sort of the the alpha that gives me
the most uh robustness so I'm gonna
Define you know um our Alpha as this
expected KL
um
for my alpha divergences or sorry my
Alpha posteriors and then our tilde
Alpha is just going to be the same thing
but for the the variational
approximations right and then my goal is
going to be uh optimize our Alpha R
tilde Alpha with respect to Alpha to to
find the um
you know the the most robust uh
procedures
okay so um right this is what I'm uh
this is what I'm I'm trying to to find
um I you know you you all believe me
that I can do this right we know the
kale Divergence between
um gaussian distributions and so um
these are these are the the results so
um basically what this says as if we
study um the the optimal Alphas we find
you know at least asymptotically that
these are going to be values strictly
less than one right so this says that
some tempering of the posterior
um in fact it gives us the the most uh
robust inference procedure
and so in particular
um you know these things depend on uh
you know this difference uh Theta naught
minus Theta star which is like the
magnitude of mispecification right so
this is kind of like how wrong uh the
original
um model is so I mean while this is like
in intuitively uh
something that that the alpha star
should depend on and you know as you get
more uh wrong more mispecified that says
Alpha should be smaller you should kind
of down weight the the likelihood more
in practice right this is something
that's like
harder if not impossible to to know
right so
um you know while this says that you
know while this does give us some
rigorous sort of uh guarantees for for
uh robustness of these procedures it
doesn't actually suggest what we should
do um in practice so uh that's just one
um limitation of the result that I'll
I'll talk a bit more about when I say
something about future
um
future work but um okay I just wanted to
to end by some sort of implications uh
of this result that I think are are
interesting so
um in particular what this allows us to
do is is compute the limit of these
optimized chaos so if you plug in these
the optimal Alphas you can look at the
kales that tell you the the sort of um
the distance from the the truth
and so um
you know uh the interesting thing is
that you know when we plug in the
optimal Alphas both of the terms
increase logarithmically and the
magnitude of mispecification but if you
go to Alpha equals one so if you say no
tempering
um of the the posterior then um these
kales will increase linearly in the
magnitude of mispecification so the
tempering right says that the way that
you kind of Zoom away from the truth in
terms of of KL is a different like
magnitude if you do some some tempering
here
um I'll also say that uh under some
conditions that that we can characterize
um optimize variational approximations
to the alpha posteriors are actually
more robust than the optimized Alpha
posteriors so
um I was sort of surprised at first that
you get additional robustness with the
variational approximation but kind of um
you know upon some reflection perhaps I
I shouldn't be right so it's like in
some sense we know that if you just
smooth things uh when you you uh
estimate right that can give you some
sort of
um robustness so what we're doing with
the gaussian mean field uh you know
approximation is is simplifying as
smoothing in some sense so it's not
surprising that there are some settings
where where this helps you out
so um you know kind of like uh my my
sales pitch right would be that that
this perhaps provides a rationale for
using variational inference due to its
robustness properties
um on top of you know you know usually
people use VI because it's it's
computationally uh very nice especially
uh you know compared to mcmc
um but you know we also get some nice uh
robustness as well
um so I'll just uh okay oh End by just
saying a few um uh kind of uh open
questions right
um so in particular I think a big
question is like how do you actually
um select Alpha and practice right so I
gave some theoretical results that like
give me nothing to say to practitioners
about what to actually do right and so
um that's not great and we'd like to
have you know something uh that that we
could suggest to do in practice and so
um we're starting to work on those with
my student rushira who is going to give
a poster uh tomorrow so you know she's
looking at you know if we select Alpha
in a data driven way
um you know what what is this sort of
tell us right and so one of the the the
reasons that um this work or you know
data driven Alpha doesn't apply here is
that if you use data to select Alpha
then Alpha is going to change within as
well right so
um you need some more tools to kind of
study what happens
um there so come to to the poster if
you're you're interested to see uh what
we've done so far and then as I
mentioned earlier right
um you know these are kind of you know
we
these results rely on the asymptotic
normality pretty heavily right and so
the question would be if we want to go
to more complicated models like the
general networks right
um
how can we can we play the same sort of
uh game right and so they are you know
the asymptotic normality
um isn't going to be there there are
some asymptotic studies but you know
that limiting distributions are more
implicit in these sorts of things so
um a kind of open question is like what
can this say and and um sort of the the
Bayesian neural networks or what can the
style of argument say in the the
Bayesian neural networks world
um so I think on that I will uh stop and
pick a few questions
[Applause]
and it was a little bit uh it would so
so I guess it still says with some
probability I'm you know I'm good right
what if you have this sort of idea of
fizzing this model somehow uh from a
class that become gradually better yes
okay so would you would you get similar
um yeah okay so
I yeah I I didn't give you all the
details about the Epsilon and because
it's it's it's complicated so in fact
you know what we need for you know these
results to make sense has that Epsilon
uh grows kind of like a constant over in
so what this means you know is that
um ultimately my you know Epsilon to the
probability of the specification so as
your data grows you're becoming more and
more sure that you're correctly
specified
um and so I will mention that this is a
non-standard model for mispecification
um
you know uh we went back and forth with
the reviewers for uh a minute um about
this
um but I'll give you a pitch for why I
think it's at least
um reasonable you know that you should
become more sure as you you get more
data so I think the idea we're imagining
is kind of we have a really careful
modeler who you know has invested a lot
of time and energy into finding a a
reasonable model but you know you still
have to acknowledge that there's some
chance that that it's wrong and so the
fact that you could get more sure with
more data right this seems to be
reasonable based on like sort of the
idea that we believe in model checks
based on the data right so we should
also believe that if we get more data
we're we're more sure
um
yeah so okay so the question I guess is
like uh what happens if we're not in
this regime in some sense or no no I
would say I was thinking that maybe
there are other ways to interpret it the
easy one like if it was gaussian so I'm
like increasing the resolution of the
models and so that I have uh instead of
this probabilistic interpretation I have
some complexity
um and I was wondering if the you think
that my products will work there because
also it's nicely you know it's like
if if the model
the class of the models that you're
considering are becoming richer because
I mean I love it
but I think it's very powerful and I I
yeah yeah I mean at some level I yeah
you know uh my deep down my feeling is
that you know this is perhaps not
exactly the right way
um and I think that perhaps you know
maybe what you're saying I
I think that we could
be willing to at least explore uh the
same sort of analysis and and the way
you're suggesting I don't it's not
obviously not going to work or something
um but uh yeah yeah I mean there there's
still some you know we're still thinking
a lot about what the correct notion of
the specification actually is you know I
guess it's not it might show the answer
I'm going to make a comment
Rafael set it up
um there's some connection between this
and this kind of robustness and machine
learning can
correct from you know you start with one
space you're actually mapping back to
another space but some bounds that can
do it for very simple models
it complicated the dimensions that
database
I think there's like a lot of directions
to to go here and you know so what I
want to ask you is is Alpha star a
function of X which it should be
[Music]
the alpha star
um
okay
uh yeah so the okay so the the thing I
showed up there was asymptotic so in to
Infinity
um but we have uh you Alpha star
finite will be
uh
yeah so it will be a function of the the
data but it's a little bit um the finite
n Alpha star is like implicit in some
sense so like this is why we present the
um the asymptotic version because you
get like a a clean sort of you know
something interpretable um but yeah
thank you nice
our last week for this session is Rafael
oliviera